and I get to take them through the world
and I have a really good support system
they're also awesome Travelers they're
good kids like if it didn't work for
them we wouldn't be able to do it but
it's I'm so lucky to be able to take
them on tour and to be able to write the
schedule like Willow and I had a really
teary conversation is it okay if I talk
about you
thanks Willow and I had a really teary
conversation about this tour because she
has needs now
I didn't even know I was going to get my
period I didn't know I mean I thought I
was being murdered from within to be
honest with you
I was like I knew it
and Willow and I talk about every almost
every we have a great relationship